[Music]
eric is with us eric
is in san antonio hey eric what's up
hey dave how you doing first time caller
here
got a question for you about um career
okay
so effectively i'm i'm in a role as a
business analyst but i'm kind of i'm
kind of trying to exit this
career field and become a financial
advisor i just find that that's what
gives me the most
joy and i think dopamine surges
in life is helping people with their
finances um
that being that being said my wife and i
are still in baby step two
uh we're down from about a hundred
thousand to forty thousand remaining
we've got a bit to go we just recently
had a baby
so our income has been cut just to my
income
at about sixty thousand well that being
said i um
i have this client who reached out to me
with an opportunity
it's again a business analyst role for
about a hundred thousand
um i just wonder you know if i should
take it even though i'm trying to exit
this arena
you know just to get that increase in
and pay be debt free in a year flat and
then move on with my career aspirations
or if i should not be pursuing something
that is not
in line with my long-term goals
uh so so uh if you move to
a financial advisor what do you make
you know i think it largely determined
it's largely determined by
the uh the commission that i would be
able to
uh to learn i think starting out from
what i've seen
it can range from 60 on up through
i mean theoretically sky's the limit i
mean if you're just going to be a
you know just just a total superstar i
mean you can read quite a bit
um so it you know i think starting out
it may be comparable though
to what i'm meaning now okay comparable
except that it has upside
based on your performance correct yes
sir
and it's in and it's doing what you love
idea
yes well go do that
right so you would not take the uh go do
that and make a hundred
60 60 is your downside
if you go do that and you make 70 or 80
versus taking 100 and then you turn
around walk back out on those people who
hired you
a year later that's kind of why no i'm
not telling you do that
i i should clarify it was it's a
contract
it was a one-year contract for a project
so it's like i i would kind of have the
red carpet on the way
out really you know because it's a
one-year contract i
i thought that would have been tacky too
if i just quit after yeah
okay that's helpful that's helpful
information
that makes me more tempted to do it but
i tell you what i would do i would sit
down with your financial advising firm
that you're talking about going with
and say okay i got this i got this
carpet ride for a year for a hundred
i got a brand new baby my wife's off i
can knock out my debt doing that
um but if i can see my way to making 100
here if you can show me what it takes to
do that and i can believe i can do it
i'll probably just come do that
okay and if not if not i'll probably see
you in a year
right right okay you kind of use it as a
leverage so
if they say if they say look the top uh
the top three percent of people hired
into this role
go you know they don't make 60 they make
100 the first year
don't do it take the carpet ride but if
they say
you know half our guys make 100 the
first year
well surely god you can get in the top
half
yeah i would hope so you know that's
what i'm you know that's the way i'm
looking at it that's why i would look at
it if it was me doing it i just go you
know i think i can get in the top half i
don't know if i can get in the top three
percent i may not be that smart
or or may not work as hard or i may not
have the golden touch i don't know
whatever
three percent would bother me but but if
there's a it's a 50
of the people that try this can do it
and make 100 first year then i'm dude
i'm doing what i love
because you have a high probability of
doing what you love of earning more
right
so right either way 12 months 12 months
from now you're doing it right
right either that's that's my goal
unless some unforeseen event comes in
and i
just fell in love all over again with
business analysis which i just don't
know
yeah i don't think that's gonna happen
um so what what runs through my head is
if you call me up and said uh i make 60
and i got a part-time job offer for 40
uh or i can quit my job and go make 60
and not have the part-time job i i you
know
and i hate the part-time job i would
tell you go do the part-time job
and get out of debt for a year you got a
baby clear your debt up and get yourself
going right
and in a sense that's kind of what we're
doing we're taking a one-year part-time
job
that's 40 over what you're being paid on
contract and it's okay to be on contract
because you're bailing
anyway 12 months from now to go into the
advisor side of the world
because that's what gives you the juice
right
yeah so it sounds like from from what
you're saying that there's
depending on the numbers and the
circumstances either of these
decisions could work out being the the
wiser choice there's not one
if you've got a reasonable probability
that you think you can hit without being
ego based or
weird you know of hitting it at advisor
go do it as an
advisor but if the probability is very
small like almost none of our guys make
100 the first year
go take the hundred do it for a year
clean it up do it for your young family
that's like working an extra job it's
one year
it's one year you can do anything for
you and then you're done
but yeah just talk talk it through with
your the company you're talking about
going on with us
with as an advisor i think they can give
you real numbers and if they're just
trying to blow
smoke then you know you got to get
somebody to really tell you what's
really going on in that world
i don't know is the answer from me i i
don't know what you can do there
or what their commission structure is or
how they pay they may say
no you're not allowed to do anything
that increases your income you're locked
at 60 for the first 12. oh well
in that case i'm for sure taking this
carpet ride